I mean you know jury is just something
that's like part of you as an artist you
know I mean like I'm into jury cars
fashion you know saying women this
Pappas GQ is Tiger and you'd like to
check out some of my personal jury by
hearing on the rocks this is a Richard
mill this is the investment anything
like just straight factory clean its RM
11 or the most popular I was to get this
watch like five years ago like a couple
years ago up I was like seventy thousand
years old
the value goes up in it I got this way
to be amazed cuz I was like I had a blue
Margiela outfit and I was like I just
thought it was dope I'm not really into
Hugh blows like that though but I
thought this one was fly so I was like
I'm gonna just have to cop this one with
the alligator band on it it's real clean
actually rolls go I change a lot like I
used to be into like yellow go super
heavy like you're gonna mean like my
histogram was I can go change you know I
mean and I just switched it up and now
just start going white you switch it up
you know then baller did this one this
is like saluting inspiring and I did it
like the mere comedic camel so it's like
green and white camo and has like the
Louie on it it's like if you can see it
matches I mean with the Louie logo on it
the green and white I actually have a
grill to that's all like like that so
this one was like twenty twenty dollars
it's heavy - it's got some weight on it
this is like my everyday kind of like
joint that I just don't
this is just what I want to like double
up I got another one like this I didn't
bring it because I was traveling I was
coming from Morocco I wish I would have
brought my mic I have like this custom
dragon logo it's like oh I style it's
crazy I just had that idea cuz I was
just on a head heavy
Asian wave like the last two years I was
spending a lot of time out there and
doing that album and
I was like y'all want to do like a
dragon Mike you know I mean this
actually take it off and this is the
Goyard logo so I wanted to do the
pattern the Goyard you know I always
like the brand so it's all white
diamonds it's made out of two chains so
it's like to Franco Cuban chains inside
of the chain like I don't know how I did
it and then II put these they're almost
like little charms I could like take
this off and then like put it on here
that's the good thing about customizing
because you could just use different
pieces for different changing them and
then a cycle Fuko yards I mean this is
very solid this is probably one of my
most expensive chains that I ever bought
this one was a quarter quarter million
to 50 better solid stones you know each
of these you could break down and make
engagement rings not seriously this one
actually I got me like early 2014 my
second album says like Hotel California
on the side of it so I've had this piece
for a long time I haven't worn in a lot
but recently I just started wearing it
it actually looks good on this chain cuz
it looks new the last Kings was
basically like my brand label I started
at the time when I came up with it I was
like really into learning about Africa
and learning about Egyptian culture and
all that stuff like that so I was just
kind of fascinated by it I don't carry a
wallet but this is like a see like a
wallet chain you know you just clip this
all to whatever the belt is iced out you
know so you can even wear it as a
necklace but I don't I just wear it as
like the waist jewelry this one is a
definitely investment piece right here
channel set in all princess cut stones
yeah it's the cut of the diamond so you
have like oval shapes is the shape and I
guess maybe because it's square I want
to say it's one of my favorite pieces
right here I don't wear it a lot though
you know the diamonds are very sensitive
when you set it like this so it could
fall out a lot you know you can't get it
cleaned a lot I try not to wear it that
much
he's like he's about four and a half
four and a half carat each solid stones
investment you can never lose you know
how when I was like 12 or something 13 I
went to like to swap meet
got him pierced you know I've just
needed that drip I needed in the back
then a lot of people was doing the two
they had like the double earrings I was
like I gotta go get the ears pierced
they're early two-thousands I feel like
was like the Golden Age they go to air
forgery I'm like Nellie had two big
number one chain and he had the single
number one nothing like a little wager
like you did he always had stones 50 but
the junit the spinning chain you know
saying with so many classic pieces
that's kind of like well I take all my
notes from then you got got like I've
made whether it's like my tuning me and
I love watching you like this it's great
you gotta make so it just depends on
your preference though what you into you
know it doesn't have to be a two million
dollar watch but you know I got very
expensive taste
I had George since I was like little
when I first met a little man I had a
fake chain but I didn't care I was just
like at this big chain I said tight on
it you probably pull up the photos I was
like 16 17 when I met that went and that
change is like it was like green gold
like it was turning gold like it the
colors was crazy but I was so excited to
have a change
you know I mean I think my first like
real chain I was like 17 I had an orange
Garfield chain that lit up feels like
all cognac orange diamonds rose gold was
like this Vagos 3d the jeweler
definitely has a input on the design cuz
he knows was gonna look best because you
might go to crazy idea like I want to do
diamonds on top of diamonds and I want
to do this but Julie knows how to make
it make sense and they know what they
can make I know like I hate waiting a
long time and like nah say you know you
got to get a new
and every album
[Music]